- Hey everyone.
I hope you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Bangkok, Thailand.
I'm handing with my friend, Drew,
- Hey, guys. How you doing?
And today we are in Silom, which is,
It's one of the main downtown financial
districts of Bangkok. Full
of sky rise office buildings,
and, so, at lunchtime,
just floods of people
come here to eat street food.
And so, we thought it
would be a lot of fun to
take you today on a Silom, Thai,
streetfood, lunch tour of Bangkok.
We're not even sure exactly
what we're gonna eat,
but we're just gonna go
to some of the popular,
famous, stalls, and share it all with you
in this video.
(traffic sounds)
That was okay.
- Could have been better.
- It was okay.
(electronic music)
- (Speaking in Thai) Okay.
Okay, the first place we're
stopping is called [Store]
Hey, what's up, man?
- Mark Wiens!
- (laughing)
- What's going on, brother?
- [Mark] What's up, man?
- Oh man, I watch ...
I watch all your food videos, man.
That's so crazy to see you.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- I'm having a little
trouble reading the font
of this Khao Man Gai spot,
but it's a chicken and rice spot called
"Khao Man Gai Ban Deed Kim."
It's right in the heart of Saladang.
Right on [Street].
If you have gotten off the
BTS at Saladang station
and walked down this road,
there's no doubt that you
have passed by this stall
many, many, times.
We're here before lunch,
it's just after 10:30 AM,
so it's not very full yet.
But if you come here ... Drew, man-
If you're here right at noon,
these tables will just be packed.
And the good thing is we're here early,
so we can get a couple meals in
before the main lunch rush arrives.
So, we're gonna have
chicken and rice first.
- Yes, sir.
- You're ready?
- Yes, man. Let's do it.
- (speaking Thai)
(grunts)
- [Mark] Oy. (laughs)
(knife hitting chopping block)
(speaking Thai)
(chair being pulled)
- [Mark] Alright. Cool.
- [Drew] Yeah. Looks good, man.
- Yeah. As soon as you
order- Maybe we're a little-
We're on a little bit
of a wobbly table, here.
- [Mark] 'Khao' means "rice",
'Man' is like the fat, or the oil,
and then 'Gai' is "chicken".
So you have "Khao Man Gai",
"Chicken Rice" that is
exactly chicken rice.
- Sure.
- [Mark] And then there's always sauce.
You have to have sauce.
- [Drew] And we just watched a guy
chop the chicken in the back,
and you know- he really dissects it
at a perfect angle every time.
- [Mark] They also sort of
flatten it with the knife,
- [Drew] Right.
so that it ... Yeah, it
just fits beautifully
over your plate of rice.
- Yep.
- [Mark] Before we try the sauce,
let's just try a bite of the rice,
'cause either rice has got to be fragrant.
You can see that it's
just kind of glistening.
Cheers.
- (humming)
- Garlic-y. Right?
- It is, yeah.
I like the rice. It's very fluffy.
- It's delicious, man.
- And it is very fragrant.
And you can feel each
individual grain of rice
because it's so fluffy.
Then, you got the chicken,
which is actually
almost... It's very moist.
Very succulent chicken.
(traffic and people speaking)
- That chicken's so soft.
- It's time to sauce.
I believe there's some
[Sauce Name] in here
from what I can smell.
It's fermented soy beans,
but then there's also
ginger and chilies in here.
It really is all about the sauce.
I mean, the chicken
and rice are excellent,
but the sauce is almost drinkable.
And you can see the
shredded ginger in there.
Let me get a nice, good, giant,
bite to just maximize the sauce.
- That sauce. Addicting, that flavor.
- [Mark] It's the fermented
soy beans, which make up
most of that flavor.
- [Drew] Right.
But that gives it such a depth of flavor.
Then, you've got the ginger in there.
- The ginger kind of kicks in after.
When you said, then I started tasting it,
but the first taste is not ginger.
- So, they only add a little bit of ginger
to the actual sauce.
That's why there's an entire bowl full of
extra ginger for people
like us that need it.
And the, of course, chopped chilis.
Okay. That should be good
for the next few bites.
Maybe a little bit of extra sauce on there
for extra good measure, of course.
Oh, and that is a perfect bite.
(traffic sounds and people speaking)
(humming)
- With that extra ginger.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But even the
ginger is not that pungent,
'cause I believe that it's young ginger.
- You can tell if it's young or old?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's experience, guys.
- Oh, yeah.
He knows if it's young or old ginger.
- [Mark] Younger ginger is more juicy
and a little bit sweeter.
Then, the final component
to Khao Man Gai is
the chicken soup.
And there's some winter
melon in here, too.
Okay, I'll eat the winter melon.
(hums) Yeah, chicken soup is nice.
That winter melon just actually dissolves
right down your throat.
(electronic music)
( traffic sounds)
- [Mark] That was a great way
to begin.
- [Drew] Yeah, dude.
- [Drew] Good little
appetizer for the day.
- We're gonna move on
now to the next spot,
which is just down the road,
and hopefully they're open.
( people speaking and traffic noises)
- [Mark] It's now 11 AM,
so a lot of carts are starting to set up.
Street food is starting to set
up for the main lunch rush.
I think we can fit two lunches in
before the main lunch.
- Absolutely.
Before the real lunch.
- Absolutely. I'm looking forward to it.
- We're getting a head start.
(traffic sounds)
- [Mark] Passing by this place,
it's called [Store Name].
This is one of my absolute favorite places
for green papaya salad.
- That's one of the best.
- Oh, my favorite.
(electronic music)
- We walked almost- it's almost to Satun,
which is the adjacent business,
financial district of Bangkok.
But we just made it to the
spot, this is the place.
- Alright, Drew. Oh, cool. They have these
stands for the chair.
- Oh, yeah.
Look, they have your chair
standing up there.
- Whoa.
- Never seen that before.
- [Waitress] (speaking in Thai)
- (speaking in Thai)
Awesome.
(laugh)
- What just happened?
(laughing)
- So, we just decided to get beef ...
(speaking in Thai)
We decided to get beef
soup with everything.
There's meatballs,
there's the braised beef,
there is probably some
organs, there is tendon.
(people speaking in Thai)
- When we ordered a mix of everything,
it means all the meats, all the beef.
What he does is he takes
the basket strainer,
which is the boiler, he
grabs some of the fresh beef,
there's some liver there.
There is some tripe.
He sticks it in the basket,
then he blanches it real fast,
just a quick blanche, and
dunks it into that hot
beef soup. It's so aromatic.
Then, he takes some of the
pre-cooked braised beef,
which is sort of like
brisket-y, brisket-y meat.
Just blanches that real fast,
sticks it into your bowl.
Then, add some of the soup into the bowl,
then finally finishes off with some of the
fried garlic, and a sprinkle of pepper.
- So excited
- (laughs) You ready to go eat it?
- Yeah.
- Okay. Let's go back to our chairs.
- [Drew] That smells delicious
- [Mark] You can really smell
the star anise in there.
They also include some
lettuce, as well as some
water morning in there ...
- Right here, this guy.
- Yep, to it. And that even
increases the fragrance.
So, we got that Gao Lao version,
which is just a soup
with rice on the side.
You could also order this with noodles.
You can get it however you like,
and you can get whatever
organs you like as well.
- Man.
- Yeah. It's almost, it's so aromatic.
You taste all of the
Chinese herbs in there.
It has this sweetness to it.
- Kind of like soy, too.
- [Mark] I'm just gonna
reach my chopsticks in
and take whatever I get,
which in this instance,
happens to be a piece of liver
and a piece of the fresh beef.
- [Drew] That broth.
- [Mark] So fresh tasting,
because all of the meats
apart from the beef that's been braised,
everything is just flashed blanched.
- [Drew] There are all
kind of different textures
going on in here.
- [Mark] Yeah, it is.
I mean, it's not like one consistent meat.
They're different shapes, different sizes.
- [Mark] Now that we've
tried the broth and the meat,
it's time to make our sauce.
It's fish sauce in a soy sauce bottle.
You add chili, a little bit of fish sauce,
and then mainly is
chili vinegar, which is-
yep, this one would be the green sauce.
There it is. That is the perfect ...
Give that a little chopstick twirl.
That's your beef dipping sauce.
- What is this one?
- That should be liver.
- Liver.
(electronic music)
- [Mark] Into the sauce.
Oh, yes.
- [Drew] Lunch crowd is coming in.
- [Mark] Yep.
- Wow.
- Oh.
- [Drew] Spicy, sour. They
add all the kicks, man.
- [Mark] And I just kind of
almost let it sit in the sauce,
'cause this sauce is so good.
- [Drew] Dunk it.
- [Mark] Dunk it, and let it just soak.
- [Drew] Like a sponge.
(electronic music)
- [Mark] Okay, I'm gonna try meatball next
and another thing you can do
that I like to do sometimes
is ... Pour it on.
- [Drew] Pour it on?
- Dropped the ball, too.
- Oh. It's really spongy,
but firm at the same time.
- It is, yeah.
- Good.
- Go down with some rice.
- Thing about this chili sauce,
when you mix the chili
flakes with fish sauce
it becomes a liquid chili
paste and it burns your lips.
It just stays on your lips the whole meal.
Whether that's a good or bad thing ...
For me, it's a good thing,
but you're always reminded
of that spice, man.
- Oh, the tripe is incredible.
It has a snap to it.
Like a little, just wonderful,
cartilage-y crunch to it.
(people speaking and dishware sounds)
- [Mark] (speaking Thai)
now as we're leaving, it's
actually even still before,
I think it's still before
... Yeah, it's 11:50,
but you can see the Silom lunch rush now
is starting to build up.
Now there's a whole crowd
waiting to eat here,
so it's good we got here 30 minutes ago.
And by the way, the
place is called Yee Jay.
- Amazing man. Like, I'm
already getting kind of full,
and I know that's a bad thing,
because we have more coming, right?
(laughs)
- [Mark] Now we're ready
for the real lunch.
- [Drew] Can't wait.
- [Mark] But yeah, that was ...
- Give you the sweats.
- I got the sweats. I got the sweats.
- It's already humid
outside we had the soups.
- Yes. Exactly.
(laughs)
(electronic music)
(people talking)
- This is the next
restaurant street food stall.
This is a place that's
very famous for noodles
and it is right at noon.
This is perfect time
for ultimate busyness.
This is just the atmosphere
that I love so much about Bangkok.
- [Drew] Yep. Right on the street.
- Stalls, the aromas of
beautiful soups and chilis
and limes.
- Absolutely, man
- [Mark] Oh, yeah.
(speaking Thai)
(laughing)
- This places is called Kuay Teow Khae.
You can choose your size,
40 bot, 50 bot, 60 bot.
She told us that the 60 bot
version, that's the special,
that's the big bowl that
comes with everything
including Moo Grob, which
is the crispy pork belly.
(bowl being filled)
- The action and energy
here is so beautiful,
and what's noticeable when
I'm standing here by the cart
where she's assembling the noodles,
she's actually blanching the
noodles back there somewhere
you can't really see.
Then, they've got some of
the seasoning ingredients
here at the front.
The final step, if she
blanches the noodles,
then he adds in the mixed pork, the egg.
The nice touch is that he
squeezes on the lime juice.
The lime juice is not cooked out,
which preserves the flavor.
Tosses noodles, adds
on some more seasoning,
so that's ... You just smell the citrus,
the lime aroma. It smells so good.
And that's why there
are so many people here.
- Did we even get a table?
- [Mark] We're waiting for a table
because there's kind
of a queue over there.
- Okay.
So she's ...
- You ain't gonna lie.
- [Mark] No, we've got it.
We're waiting for a table.
We're in line. We're in line.
- This is the heat of the moment, guys.
This is what it's all about.
- [Mark] Whoa (speaking thai).
(crowd sounds)
- We waited about 30
minutes to get this chair,
but we finally got it.
- [Mark] Yes we did.
- You're in the frame more,
and there's more action
behind you on that side.
- Yeah, this is cool.
- That is our (dish name)(laughs)
- [Drew] Did you get that?
- [Mark] Okay, now.
- [Ying] (speaking Thai)
- [Drew] Oh, yeah.
- [Ying] Oops. Sorry.
(eltro music)
- [Mark] But it comes with
soup on the side, yeah?
- [Ying] Yeah, I think that
she's gonna bring it ... Yeah.
- [Drew] You have two cameras on you.
(laughs)
Don't worry, no pressure.
- Really good.
(speaking Thai)
- The first expression that
I'm gonna say is (speaks Thai)
means I desperately want
to eat this.(laughs)
- [Drew] This is true, this is true.
- Definitely you could put
your whole face in this bowl,
it's that big.
You've got the bami,
which are egg noodles,
but they're not the ...
spaghetti egg noodles,
but they're the thick ...
Look at that bunch of noodles.
Actually, you know what?
I just grabbed in one
chopstick all the of the
noodles in my entire bowl.
- You could eat it all in one bite.
- That's how sticky they are.
- Yeah (laugh) But they're
the semi wide egg noodles.
So, wheat based with egg,
but then all of the toppings,
you see the red barbecue
pork, you've got the moo grob,
which looks incredible, which
is the crispy pork belly.
A variety of meatball looking things,
some of the minced pork,
and just thin and wavy.
Wavy, that's what they are, they're wavy.
- Man.
- Oh, wow.
- Dude.
- [Mark] They're tangly,
and they're so ...
They're soft, but not mushy at all
and they're very, very thin.
I mean, not the width, but
the thickness is of noodles.
- [Drew] They kind of grip together
in your mouth when you chew them.
- [Mark] They do.
- [Drew] Like, they don't separate.
They kind of go in a ball in your mouth,
but it's a great ball(laughs).
- [Mark] It has a gummy
texture at the same time.
... Actually oil,
there's dry chili flakes.
There's vinegar, and this another vinegar.
These would be all the
essential seasoning for this.
Oh, look at this. This is a beauty.
- [Drew] Are you putting all that in?
- [Mark] I am putting all of this in, yes.
- [Drew] You're insane.
- [Mark] One more scoop
just for good, good measure.
Oh, perfect. Good. Then,
I'm gonna go in for also
some of vinegar and some
chili flakes as well.
Little bit of dried chili flakes on here.
Finally, some of the chili vinegar,
and probably two scoops
of this to complete my
seasoning for the moment.
- [Drew] Can I tell you something?
- [Mark] Yeah.
You want to say it on ...
- [Drew] Wait, no no.
Wait until we'll talking.
- No, go ahead.
- Alright, guys. I don't
think an average person
would put that much chili on it.
I know this guy loves spice,
but it's mind blowing how
spicy he makes his dish.
He wouldn't say say that,
so I want to say that
on the camera. That's it.(laugh)
look at that, man.
It's like, a full layer thick of spice.
- [Mark] A blanket of chili.
- [Drew] A blanket of chili,
yeah. A blanket of chili.
- [Mark] That's my
favorite kind of blanket.
Okay. I'm gonna give this a little ...
Whoa, it's kind of sliding
on the metal table.
Give this a little stir,
let it coat those noodles.
- [Drew] So good.
- [Mark] This is where things
get more and more beautiful
and more flavorful. Oh,
and the crispy pork belly.
Okay, I'm gonna definitely
get some crispy pork belly on this bite.
Check out how these noodles
have just been transformed.
- Oh my god.
Dude.
- Dude. The crispy pork belly.
Did you get a bite of that yet?
- Yeah. Wow.
- [Drew] This is our third
meal in the last hour
and even though I'm full,
this is the best one.
This is my favorite one.
- This is crazily good, yeah.
- So good.
I need a little more vinegar
to balance everything
and will be balanced out to perfection.
Okay, perfect.
- [Drew] I got to get
that pork belly, again.
- [Mark] And I'll get some moo dang,
which is the barbecue part on this bite.
- [Drew] I'm surprised that you actually
eat everything in the background.
(laughter)
- As Drew and I were filming,
Ying managed to finish her entire bowl.
- [Drew] Like, practically
clean. Look at that.
(laughing)
Ying you are a champion.
You are a champion.
- [Mark] Yeah.
That's the reason we get along so well.
- Focus there.
- [Mark] Oh, let me see that skin.
- See that skin? See that?
Oh yeah. That crunchy, but soft.
- The final component
of this dish is the soup
because we got the dry noodle soup.
The soup is on the side.
You can see the (ingredient),
which is the coriander,
the cilantro roots.
Yeah, very light. Another
thing you could do, Drew,
- Yeah?
You can take some of your soup
and add it to your
noodles to rehydrate them
as you continue to eat,
which I love to do.
It's like rejuvenating ...
- [Drew] Bringing them back to life.
Because, your noodles get a little dry.
You can keep on rolling with it.
Look at ... These are just so tasty,
I love the texture, it's great.
(electro music)
- [Mark] I think this egg is a one biter.
Oh, that yolk. Oh, it's so creamy.
(electro music)
- Down to my last bite. I
think this is a fish ball
and I'm just gonna scrape up, wipe up,
some of that final chili
oil and nuts down there.
(laughs) yes. Right off
the lip the of the bowl
with the thumb. Okay, I got it.
- Oh. Cool. That's a totally new texture.
That was one of a kind in the bowl.
- [Mark] Good job, Drew.
- Oh, dude. The best.
I'm so happy right now.
I'm so satisfied, I don't
even need to eat until dinner.
(laughs)
I mean, I meant tomorrow.
- [Mark] How's the noodles?
- Very good.
- Very good. As I've mentioned,
my lips are burning(laughs).
Welcome to Thailand. Welcome to Bangkok.
(electro music)
- So good. She is a
master. She is a master.
You've got to come here
when you're in Silom, man.
The lunch rush, it's so much energy,
it's so action packed, her noodles ...
(speaking Thai)
- She knows what she's
doing, guys. Really.
(laughing and speaking Thai)
(electro music)
- [Mark] He has called us over.
(speaking Thai)
- [Mark] You want half of the sample?
- [Drew] Yeah, dude.
- [Mark] This is one with taro inside.
We've stopped for the final
thing on this Thai street food
tour of Silom at lunch.
We've stopped at Khanom
Tokyo, which is a sweet,
it's kind of like a pancake,
which [Person] is really friendly.
This is with taro inside it.
Oh, yeah.
- It is like a pancake.
(calling sounds)
- Oh, and he's ... Okay.
He's making a fresh batch.
- [Drew] That's good. Really good.
- [Mark] Unless you want to
try to the hotdog one, we can.
- [Ying] I had the hotdog.
- [Mark] Oh, you did?(laughs)
'Cause the hotdog one has the coil in it.
(speaking Thai)
(cooking sounds)
- Lung Tokyo.
- [Mark] Lung Tokyo, mean 'Uncle Tokyo'.
- [Man] Uncle Tokyo.
(traffic sounds)
(laughing)
- [Mark] Uncle Tokyo on [Street Name],
he's such a friendly man.
He's been making this
same snack for 20 years.
- [Drew] 20 years.
- Yeah, we've already tried
some of the sweet versions.
Just snacking right off the griddle,
but the one I'm most interested to try
is the Thai 'pig in the
blanket.' The Thai corn dog.
The entire hotdog, the ketchup,
oh, the quail egg,
- [Drew] The quail egg.
is all wrapped up on a stick on a skewer.
How convenient is that?
- Oh, man.
(laughs)
Wow. I need to think about
this for a second.(laughs)
- That is oddly delicious.
- [Drew] Yeah.
It's like a sweet pancake
with a slightly mushy hotdog,
the quail egg,
- Ketchup.
And you've got that tangy ketchup.
- I vote this is great, man.
I'll come back and get this again.
- [Mark] Even if the hotdog
is not my favorite thing,
the experience ...
- it's an art in itself.
Just the art of uncle making it,
his passion for it, and his
positivity, and just ...
- [Drew] He's been doing it for 20 years,
making the same exact thing every ...
I asked him how many he sells in a day,
and he said he can't even
count 'cause he sells so many.
- [Mark] Just the convenience
of this, it's all on a stick.
You never need to touch it.
I happen to be on my final bite.
- This is kind of a sad moment.
- Yeah, I know.
That means its gonna end.
- It's kind of bittersweet.
Alright, this is the final bite of hotdog.
(electro music)
(traffic sounds)
- That was a lot of fun, and
that was a perfect ending.
Drew, what was your
favorite dish of the day?
- I have to say it was
the third one we ate,
the dried noodles, man. That was amazing.
- It was.
- Yeah.
- It really was incredibly good.
Well, we've come to the
end of this food tour.
I want to say a huge thank
you to Drew for joining me.
Drew, can you just tell
everybody what you do?
- Sure. Thanks, man. It
was a pleasure being here.
I make daily travel videos
on Facebook and Youtube.
Just two to three minute
little documentary style
telling unique stories and everything,
just like the guy that we just met.
- I'll leave all his links below.
Check him out. He also
makes videos with a message
and also really explains the culture.
Yeah, Drew is cool.
- Cool.
- Anyway, thank you all
- Thanks man
so very much for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you,
and if you're not already
subscribed, click subscribe now.
Also, you see that little bell icon?
Click that bell icon. That
way you're gonna get notified
of the next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching.
Good bye from Bangkok in Silom.
See you on the next video.
- See you guys[Thai].